the trade deadline gave us was another
unexpected trade that the rams acquire
von miller
uh we were on live when that happened we
were like whoa
you even said you even said uh when
which because you said there's been a
trade von miller's been traded yeah
you're right in the middle of something
and i was like hey breaking news and
your first line tj was
what
and then we find out it's the rams and
then i i i just uh i just went for it
and um
sung the praises of this man who's kind
enough to call into the program right
now uh on the mercedes-benz van phone
line from the los angeles rams the
general manager less need back here on
the show how are you doing les
i'm good and and because you went for it
rich i probably got more
text
with the uh if you want to call it the
the highlight
of your show
after you went for it you're you're than
i've ever gotten before are you
[Laughter]
i'll let your audience go from there let
their mind wonder well i mean i i i
mentioned how um you you walk regularly
even though uh uh uh church bells are
involved and as a matter of fact les i
think we have uh uh exclusive audio of
you
getting on the phone today there it is
[Laughter]
right is that what you're referring to
left right there you know what i
all the memes that my teenagers sent me
were were similar
or
even more graphic
oh my gosh i'm well i i'm uh i'm sorry
and i'm also very proud of myself i'll
be very honest with you uh at the same
time less so you know what you're a
creative thank you sir i'm sure that
that's in the will house
amen
you know
being a creative the last time we
chatted it seems like you
it was my wife's birthday and you know
you you admitted the maybe the bias that
you have based on the relationships but
yeah i'm not sure that your listeners do
know that probably the last time you and
i chatted we weren't really chatting i
was listening to you
like really do a really good probably
redemption of neil diamond yes i did
some karaoke
kind of birthday i worked out of my
wheelhouse that night yeah usually it's
just uh it's just sinatra but i was
going for it back in june when you're
well i guess that that's uh that's
another uh line from a sinatra song but
man uh i i just um
i just couldn't believe that trade so
let's just jump right into it uh if you
don't mind how did this start do you
bring up von miller to the power the
broncos uh i mean is that what it is
where you're you're you had made another
trade with them did you bring it up then
i know i'm asking 15 questions at one
but um
i think
you're correct in and because uh because
george zimbra you know they they had wow
have they been hit at linebacker and it
seems like you know every game one or
two were going down so
i i i know when we were discussing the
kenny young thing
you know i did bring up hey george uh i
know we're probably not doing a von
miller for kenny young trade but based
on
maybe some rumors out there based on him
being in the in the last year of his
contract based on where they asked hey
are y'all thinking of moving
vaughn and george said hey
why don't we do this let's get through
the the kenny young thing and then uh
over the next few days if that is the
case i'll circle back with you and it
does seem like at the end last week uh
george circled back so
uh that conversation did lead to
to von uh
being a ram
and then the compensation uh involved
money obviously um because
of the
draft choices that you gave up being a
second
uh and a third
for next year's draft and the money that
denver is putting towards the remainder
of his contract is that how that works
that if they had tossed less money
towards his contract the the draft
choices would have been less than
yeah i think that that is true there's a
there's kind of a sliding scale
per se when when us general manners are
chatting based on contracts like that
and and how much the team takes on
you know and what the the compensation
would be so you're exactly right there
is a sliding scale and that was the
interesting thing about this
uh trade because we were very upfront
with george
from the beginning right for us to be
able
uh to take home bond based on our cap
situation and things like that they were
gonna have to be willing to do that and
obviously they were in the end but uh
not saying it was a a deal breaker but
it was somewhat of a deal breaker based
on our situation less need general
manager of the la rams fresh off of the
von miller acquisition right here on the
rich eisens show now let's get to the uh
church bells part here i mean you're
giving up a ton of draft capital less
not just for
vonn but in addition to what you coughed
up for matthew stafford jaylen ramsey to
get here as well
at any point in time do you do you sit
down look at the ledger and go
you know
what am i doing seriously uh i mean uh
we'll definitely do that you know if i
like to say one liner we do use
we we definitely value draft picks and
i like to say
often hey we just use them in innovative
ways but when you do sit down and really
look at that ledger you're talking about
uh just quickly over the last five years
we haven't had a first round pick but
we've done a lot of maneuvering we do a
lot of trading back we acquire a lot of
picks we use the comp formula so we have
probably had the third or fourth and
fourth most draft picks of any team in
in the previous
five years even though we hadn't had a
first so
uh that's the past so you're always
right the ledger you gotta look at the
future like in this situation too rich
we
we knew uh
coming into this year we're going to get
a cop a third round comp for for brad
holmes becoming the gm of the detroit
lines and we expect to get four more
compensatory picks based on
players that we lost last year like a
john johnson starting with him and and
a host of others so with that being said
we were expecting even though we traded
those picks uh eight picks in this
year's draft so we're always kind of
looking at the past the future what we
need to do how we best utilize those
picks
and and we and our model does allow us
uh to acquire pics via you know whether
it's the comp formula or it's trading
back in the draft so what about just uh
you know passing it up the chain of
command for you just to say hey um we're
going to give up more picks i mean do
you do you have to do that or do you
have the full green right
you definitely uh
have to do that or i i would say this
whether it's a half probably it's it's
actually a philosophy i believe in right
that uh
obviously sean and i work together but
working with kevin demoth and and stan
cronkite owner making sure
right uh they're in the loop making sure
they know what uh
you know what the intentions are and
also what the ramifications are and
here's the why behind it and and like
you said here's the ledger moving
forward
and and and with that being said we're
all i always say the draft's very
important to us
uh and we believe in in utilizing every
round of the draft we we we have we
believe in collecting as many pics as
possible that way you get you obviously
get more players you get uh
a mutual fund right it's like a venture
capitalist you have a you know
more chance to have successes
and and it takes it takes a symbiotic
relationship with the coaching staff
where we can say as just a
a pitcher to paint it right we can we
can let a really good player like john
johnson move on
and we will probably recruit the fourth
round comp for him and then replacing
with a player that we drafted in the
sixth round so that takes a very uh
symbiotic relationship with the coaching
staff knowing exactly the type of
players they need uh believing in them
and their ability to develop the players
and and those coaches having the courage
to
write to
say yes let's let's roll with jordan
fuller and move on from john and that's
just the way the nfl works and before we
move on to the actual von miller um you
know a scheme and what's to be done with
him now and for the future um less need
last one for you on just this whole
subject about roster maneuvering and
valuing draft picks and trading a lot of
them for real deal people right here
right now i'm sure you've heard also in
the media the conversation that boy this
just proves the rams are all in for this
year and i'm i'm sure you laugh at
something like that like you know every
year you're like you know what uh we're
we're only halfway in you know
we're fine if we just reach the uh the
divisional round you know you know i
mean like of course you want to win the
super bowl every year that said this
sure looks like every single chip that
you have at your disposal is now pushed
right to the middle of the table to make
sure you do what the bucks did last year
which is win it in your own building
would you agree with that based on this
well
we're very aware of of where we're at
right now and what's interesting right
we've got seven wins but we're the fifth
seed and right now we're traveling uh
you know
in the wild card round uh
to play so we still have work to do to
to win a division and and to get you
know make heck try to buy for that buy
so you're we're always aware of where
we're at
uh and toward the end of the season
based on how you're playing injuries you
know there's realistic expectations but
rich i do i often say we're not
our vision is not to build something to
just win one game it's to build
something to win a lot of games and uh
as many as possible and when you're able
to do that right you you you're able to
put yourself in position to write if you
want to call it ski for the gold medal
but similar to our last five years with
sean
you know we have the third most wins of
any team so
i only say that to say yes
every year is important but also
uh we also look at you know the bigger
picture the longer term and and and it's
not just one year but we hope to do it
many years i mean you you you could even
go into your ledger and envision von
miller sticking around stan
i know we did when we made the trade uh
based on the position he played based on
his pedigree based on right you can
watch it he he's not necessarily losing
uh a step and a lot of times players of
his caliber
right can you know they got they got
more gears than most so even as they age
and they lose the gear they're still one
or two gears ahead so we did talk with
vaughn and and his representation about
making this
a little more than than one year but we
all agreed let's let's get through the
next 48 72 hours transition bond here
and then go from there on that so oh wow
yes he's definitely going to help us
this year we'd like to have him help us
the next year and the years into the
future as well so
it's not i thought you were going to go
let's just get through this season like
you're you're willing to start talking
about this right now
for uh we're definitely willing to start
talking about it you know
uh sooner than later that's that's been
a vision and we we communicated that
with uh
his his representation and we agreed to
do that what was that phone call with
sean like to say hey by the way uh yeah
we got von miller what was that like for
you less well
the phone call once once sean realized
it was realistic uh you know he checked
in on the on the hour every hour but i
do remember the the first conversation i
had with him yeah he was like
you i i think he used the quote with our
media your your and then you can add
your you know block bleep bleep bleep
and based on that was hey we got a
chance to get von miller and oh by the
way
how do we pay for that well they're
willing to do their part in helping us
with that based on that sliding scale we
talked about before so once he knew i
wasn't pulling some type of halloween
prank or april fool's early prank on him
right he was all in so then what's the
scheme can you uh can you what what can
you reveal like what's the hell is this
going to look like i mean that's this is
crazy but what do you envision
it'll be interesting what it will look
like but what what we do know is and
what we found out over the last couple
of years is obviously when you have
aaron donald a lot of teams are going to
try to do their best to make sure he
doesn't
wreck the game and a lot of times just
hey there's five offensive linemen and
there's there's running backs and tight
ends and and let's call it the eligibles
that can go out
so
with aaron a lot of times teams will
you'll hear people say slide protect
right they're going to slide a side of
the line the air and so there's often
two and three hands on air and and and
that that lines kind of taking care of
air inside
well if you when we had leonard floyd on
the other side teams could maybe use a
tight end or running back even though i
obviously was a chip double team
floyd so what it's going to do by adding
this third piece is it's definitely
going to stress
and put pressure on how
uh let's call it the
the offensive staff plans to
uh come up with their protection schemes
on those tuesday nights and then it's
also going to stress and pressure them
you know during the game because it
you know now you're not just trying to
take two away you're trying to you're
trying to you're definitely game
planning for three instead of two right
now and then of course everything's
local just like politics and real estate
right and building rosters too um you
make a deal like this figuring okay this
helps get kyler on the ground russ when
his pin is removed from his finger
lance if that's somebody who we got to
see right that's what this
that's a great point
in our division
if you
especially with kyler and russell you
you've got to stop them from beating you
passing the ball and oh by the way they
got that extra pitch in their or their
next extra club in their golf bag and
that's being able to escape and and and
beat you with their legs and
having athletes over the years we've had
some success with those players when we
have those type athletes that can run
east to west and it not necessarily stop
them but contain them and obviously
having bond uh on on the other side
helps that all right les my kids are
catching the ball in the backyard you
know uh 13 10 and eight so they might be
available for your next first round
draft choice um i'll keep them uh
practicing you know
for that for that for that eventuality
you know
yeah that's you know what we hadn't gone
to the ledger then but you know we'll
look into the future and kind of see how
that looks and okay you know but it does
seem like that's a different rams team
the next cooper cup
that's right cooper eisen the next
cooper cup don't forget that don't
forget that
it's it's it's it's our house eyes and
house that's what i want them to start
screaming and and so far at some point
in time but i bet you have gray hair by
this
you'll still have hair i know that les
thanks for the time man appreciate it
congrats on the deal let's do this again
all right appreciate it richard it's
less neat everybody general manager of
the los angeles rounds
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here